[Música]
Bienvenidos a un nuevo episodio de La
Crónica de medio ambiente en France 24
yo soy María Clara calle y hoy vamos a
conversar de un tema que normalmente
pasa desapercibido cuando hablamos de
dióxido de carbono solemos centrar la
atención en los combustibles fósiles
como el petróleo Pero hay otra industria
que es una de las mayores contaminantes
la construcción si miramos los gases de
efecto invernadero por sector la
construcción como tal solo es
responsable del 6% de los gases pero hay
que tener en cuenta que la electricidad
y la producción de calor están
estrechamente ligados con los lugares
donde vivimos y donde trabajamos por eso
cuando las emisiones se miden por la
energía que se requiere la contaminación
por construcción aumenta a más de un 40
por ciento y lo que la agencia
internacional de energía cataloga como
las Industrias y las otras industrias de
la construcción se refiere a las
emisiones que se generan por crear
materiales es como el concreto el acero
y el aluminio de hecho tan solo el
cemento que es uno de los tres
materiales básicos para crear el
concreto emite entre el 5 y el 10% de
todos los gases de efecto invernadero en
el mundo pues para producirlo la piedra
caliza se tiene que calentar a más de
1400 grados Celsius por eso desde hace
muchos años existen iniciativas para
impulsar nuevos materiales que sean
sostenibles con el medio ambiente como
nos lo explicó crack White director de
homes en Reino Unido
uno de los retos que tenemos con los
materiales de la construcción Es que
para hacerlos y llevarlos al lugar donde
construimos tenemos que usar mucha
energía y eso emite más CO2
Entonces el camino ahora es
descarbonizar la construcción y lo
podemos lograr usando materiales
reciclados
y Mejor aún con materiales biobasados
como madera paja y cáñamo
Y eso reducirá el impacto esos
materiales en nuestro ambiente
estas iniciativas están en todo el mundo
y Juan Manuel Vázquez director del
Instituto latinoamericano Pacific House
explica por qué en lugares como América
Latina hay una ventaja natural
justamente como decía de los materiales
biobasados es que los materiales
biobasados son producto de la
fotosíntesis y como países en Vía de
desarrollo estamos en una posición donde
la Cuenca fotosintética es muy grande la
combinación de calor y temperatura en
nuestros países latinoamericanos hace
que los materiales biobasados crezcan
más entonces podemos decirlo como que
somos millonarios en fotosíntesis y eso
es una oportunidad única que tenemos en
Latinoamérica otra de las razones para
potenciar materiales como la madera o la
paja es que los actuales como el cemento
y el concreto los estamos
sobreexplotando Juan Manuel explica que
el mundo produce 12.000 millones de
toneladas de áridos en el mundo mientras
que consumimos 48 mil millones siendo
los áridos un elemento esencial para el
concreto
el cemento es solo una cuarta parte en
el hormigón las otras tres cuartas
partes son los áridos hay una
megaminería en el mundo de la que nadie
habla que es la construcción cementicia
y hay una crisis de áridos tan
importante que tenemos la paradoja de
que el Burj Khalifa edificio hoy más
alto del mundo
828 metros de puro hormigonera Cero en
el medio del desierto
está construido con arena traída de
Australia la arena del desierto no sirve
para construir porque está es verificada
por el viento no tiene aristas entonces
fíjate hasta el punto que llegamos no
Además en la construcción existen dos
tipos diferentes de carbono uno es el
carbono operacional son las emisiones
que se producen por la energía que usan
los edificios por ejemplo para cocinar o
para calentar o ventilar un ambiente
otra clase es el carbono capturado que
es el CO2 que surge al crear y
transportar los materiales para la
construcción los expertos nos explicaron
qué soluciones se pueden aplicar desde
el punto de vista de del carbono
operacional lo que tenemos que hacer es
edificios más eficientes
en esto que Creek hablaba que es cuánto
nos cuesta a nosotros la calefacción la
refrigeración el agua caliente sanitaria
nuestros edificios desde ese punto de
vista por ejemplo con un estándar como
el passing House tenemos esos resuelto
ahora desde el punto de vista del
carbono operativo la base es usar estos
materiales biobasados o sea reemplazar
materiales que emiten carbono por
materiales que secuestran carbono y en
eso Creek siempre tiene una frase que es
construyamos con carbono hay otra frase
interesante de cra él afirma que el
carbono es la nueva moneda de cambio
Pues si la cifra de estructuras se
convierten en Sumidero de CO2 esto no
solo ayuda al planeta sino que también
se convierte en un negocio de hecho en
Reino Unido ya hay cerca de 100
compañías que quieren comprar el
almacenamiento de carbono que promueven
empresas como las de
en el comercio de carbono es un mercado
emergente en todo el mundo generalmente
se entiende que es en compensación en la
que por ejemplo si tienes que volar a un
lugar puedes compensar tus emisiones de
carbono invirtiendo en una plantación de
bosque o en economías emergentes
Pero hay otra cosa que es la captura y
almacenamiento de carbono como estamos
trabajando con materiales fotosintéticos
que han absorbido CO2 esto se quedan con
el carbono y dan oxígeno a cambio
ahora almacenamos ese átomo de carbono
en nuestros edificios
y comenzaremos a comercializar el
almacenamiento y ya no solo con la
compensación
con estas soluciones terminamos nuestra
Crónica ambiental Vean este y todos los
capítulos en France 24.com
[Música]